hey it's Justine and we are kicking off
new Apple tech season with the brand new
sort of brand new airpods Pro 2 USBC
[Music]
now there are some things that are new
but essentially the biggest upgrade is
the fact that we are able to charge
these with USBC which would make sense
because now all of the iPhones are USBC
compatible so we got to start making all
of the accessories USBC compatible so
here it is step one let's unbox them and
check them out
so if you just look at the case it looks
exactly like the previous version but
look at that Port have you seen anything
more beautiful
also in the box we have different sized
ear tips and these ear tips have pretty
much changed my life because previous to
this I was not able to use any of the
airpods pro because they always fell out
but now that they introduced this extra
small ear tip they work perfectly with
my ear type like USBC cable what a treat
I'm gonna put the new ear tips on right
now so we'll just pop these off of the
tray pop off the old ones
foreign
there they are good as new ready for my
small ear holes so like I said the
airpods Pro 2 are my favorite now that
they work with my ears I have been using
them non-stop since I got them one thing
I will say is they are actually pretty
durable I have put them through some
things I use them almost every single
day and they even went through a full
wash cycle and they ended up drying out
and working perfectly fine and I still
use them all the time so now when it
comes to the brand new airpods Pro 2
with USBC charging case there is only
two new differences and the main one is
quite obvious there's a new USBC
charging port but this port is kind of
exciting because this will allow you to
charge USBC to USBC on your new iPhone
15. and the other new thing is lossless
audio we're gonna have the ability to
use this with Vision Pro which will be
coming out at some point and I cannot
wait to try that so obviously if you are
going to be getting a Vision Pro then
making the upgrade to the USBC case
might be for you so you'll be able to
fully experience that latency free
lossless audio with your Vision Pro this
is kind of big news that app has
unlocked lossless audio in their
ecosystem because you may see this
elsewhere with the H2 chip right now it
is only going to be with the Vision Pro
but who knows what the future holds now
let's take a look at some of the
features that are new in iOS 17 with the
new airpods Pro so first of all let's
get these all synced up I love the
syncing process it's so easy seamless
there we go time to connect here's the
new adaptive audio mode so we have
adaptive audio we can do personalized
volume and conversational awareness
we're going to turn on adaptive mode
turn on a personalized volume and the
conversation awareness this is really
pretty impressive this lowers the media
when you start speaking so if you're
having a conversation and you're
listening to music the audio in your
airpods will automatically start
lowering while you're having a
conversation and then when the
conversation's over the volume goes back
up mute and unmute so I'm kind of
excited about this you're able to mute
and unmute yourself on a call there are
so many times that I have my phone in my
pocket when I'm on calls it's usually
like a zoom call so I'm not able to like
mute or unmute myself so if I have my
phone in my hand it's it's a whole thing
and you know the struggle if you've done
any conference calls in your lifetime
press once on airpods Pro to mute or
unmute your microphone when on a call
Joanna call you can press twice now to
change some of these settings you can go
directly into the airpods in the control
center so you'll have your noise control
transparency so you can have
transparency adaptive and noise
cancellation so I'm going to set mine to
Adaptive this is really cool because it
will still block out sounds but it'll
leave in important sounds like car horns
or bike bells or somebody yelling at you
to get your attention you can also
switch the different transparency modes
by pressing and holding so you can turn
on active noise cancellation but every
time I start talking it automatically
turns it down if you do want to sing
along to a song that's in your airpods
and you don't want the volume to lower
you will have to manually go in and turn
off the conversational awareness since
it will think that you're having a
conversation so I'm going to test out
the conversational awareness so I'm
going to start playing some music and
then I'm going to start talking and see
what happens okay it's pretty loud
volume went down instantly right there
already dropped down it's so cool so
like I can to say something to me hi hey
how's it going so I hear you okay now
stop talking yeah I can okay now
hey Justine I'm over here can you hear
me I'm I'm noticing you and I want to
get are you saying something so yeah so
I have to initiate so I see oh excuse me
sir are you saying something to me now
my volume is lower so now I can hear you
whoa right sick oh I'm so excited about
these new updates this is really cool
again this isn't just on the USBC ones
this is on the airpods pro lineup oh
gosh my music just turned up like this
is so great like I could wear these all
day now like I don't have to take them
out because as soon as I say something
the volume turns down normally you do
this little thing like hold on one
second
uh what did you say
no now it's just I start talking
and it this is great I love this I'm so
excited anyway let me show you the
differences between the USBC and the
lightning case this is USBC
this is lightning they look pretty much
identical except the fact that this one
is brand new and super shiny and there's
no scuffs or scratches
something else that I didn't even think
that I would be as obsessed with as I am
is the little lanyard holes that they
put in this came in the last version in
the airpods Pro 2 and of course it's
here in I'm calling it 2.5 because
that's what it feels like there's still
an upgrade it's still two but uh it's
2.5 so check that out we can put a
little lanyard in and
there you go you do have to be careful
though if you swing these around and get
really Rowdy the top of this will come
out and your airpods will go flying not
speaking from any type of experience or
anything so hyped about these I also got
this from my iPhone which I'm kind of
excited about anchor has this whole line
of new accessories for USBC charging
look at that I can charge my airpods in
it now too because it's USBC what do you
guys think of the new USBC airpods are
you excited about this are you hyped
about uspc I would love to hear it leave
me some comments below listen if you're
not already subscribed I definitely
recommend you doing so because there
will be new Apple videos to come I
promise and if you want to watch more
videos I'll have some here on the end
screen for you to check out and I look
forward to seeing you in the next one
bye